career-best not make any more threats to
the United States they will be met with
fire fury and frankly power the likes of
which this world has never seen before
and it's about time that somebody stuck
up for the people of this country and
for the people of other countries if
anything happens to Guam there's going
to be big big trouble in North Korea
Rocketman is on a suicide mission for
himself and for his regime critics
knocked him for his tough talk and they
claimed the president's rhetoric on
North Korea could lead us to war boy
were they as shocked as the rest of us
by the breakthrough that no one saw
coming
the prospect of a peaceful resolution to
the nuclear standoff Kim jong-un is now
willing to meet in person with President
Trump for talks and this is in fact a
stunning development here's more from
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson willing
and his strong desire for talks I think
it was really what changed was his
posture in a very dramatic way that in
all honesty was the potential a bit of
surprise to us as well that he was so
forward leading his conversations with
the delegation from South Korea it will
take several weeks to agree on timing
and location for the talks but the
president said it will happen by May he
is of course winning some unusual praise
from critics but there's also plenty of
skepticism about upcoming sit down okay
skipping you Greg oh okay most of this
would be going down as a great president
and there's no way around that
why has no sitting American president
ever met with a leader from North Korea
why has that never happened in all the
decades North Korea's existed as a
nation why hasn't any other president
ever done should I take that to mean
that this might be a particularly risky
or even an unwise move there's a better
chance that a meeting between Kim
jong-un and Donald Trump could actually
be successful this is a great a
breakthrough and a significant
opportunity for us if we play it play it
right it's not just about Donald Trump
it's about moon jae-in Kim jong-un is
getting something that his father and
grandfather wanted the optics of sitting
down at the table as equals face to face
with the President of the United States
in this case Donald Trump okay Danna so
do you think that the president is
getting you know appropriate kind of
evaluation and consideration for the
steps that he's taking that have
resulted in this historic out unbalance
I think so I think he's getting I would
have call it a net plus in terms of
coverage for him on this with with a
little dose of skepticism not about the
president but about Kim jong-eun and
appropriately so because in 1996 and in
2005 they tried the same thing
not exactly face-to-face talks but they
wanted talks in exchange for something
and in this case it seems that depending
on what kim jeong-hoon actually does
they might actually get nothing for it
right they want the talks for what
they're going supposedly he says he
won't do any missile tests between now
and whenever this meeting takes place
and we haven't heard other things from
Kim jong-un of what
you would want now that said it is a
different situation now than to 1996 or
2005 because apparently it is does have
nuclear weapons now so he comes to the
table in a much different position but I
think there's no doubt that on the
president's stance and his willingness
to be really tough plus if you look at
there's always been this thing that Kim
jong-un was worried that he would become
Saddam Hussein and there's a reason that
Gaddafi turned over his nuclear weapons
because they realized that America like
was not going to put up with it anymore
I but so but back to your question just
as President Trump getting enough credit
I think so and I think I think that also
he can't worry about it too much because
leadership is doing things that might
not necessarily be popular at the time
but looking back could be very popular
for example when he said fire and fury
back in I don't know where was that last
spring and he was at Bedminster and
there was a huge fire fight about that
in the media like oh my gosh it's so
bellicose and he's gonna lead us to
nuclear war well actually looking back
and even in Vanity Fair in the New York
Times and several of those people there
Podesta and I'm sorry Panetta and
Brennan are all looking back saying it's
actually worked and getting to this
point so I think on balance he's getting
enough credit yeah and if that's what
the goal is the goal shouldn't be
necessarily credit it's the outcome
which is denuclearizing North Korea
absolutely so and that's the intended
outcome and perhaps the eventual outcome
but nevertheless if you look at the time
frame here congressman this is quite
quick turnabout for president Trump
coming in and being able to achieve this
kind of diplomatic you know Accord in
terms of being able to sit down with him
to discuss this and to do something that
benefits not only the United States but
you know the rest of the world it
reminds me of what Ronald Reagan did he
took this doctrine of peace through
strength and I think Donald Trump laid
down the line real early earned a
reputation that he was willing to do
what it took to protect the United
States protect wom and and the allies
that we have around the country are
around the world and I think that's
paying off in great dividends and it did
happen fairly quickly and there gonna be
a lot of gyrations and if they delay the
time liner right now but we need to let
this play out because pres
Trump has put us in a position where we
can actually prevail and make the world
a better safer place okay Gregg well if
I leave this world AMA they would
already of demolished Mount Rushmore and
they put for Obama heads right there but
the I want to hit the point about the
optics they say uh by elevating Kim it's
it the optics art he's getting something
for nothing it may actually help rocket
man but that's why would he do why
wouldn't he do it the point is that's
going to be part of the deal he's going
to be in a deal that is going to
probably help him survive but in order
to for this to succeed we have to be
super skeptical and we also have to have
make sure that there is restitution for
otto warmbier right he has to be part of
this equation and President Trump has
spent a lot of time with Otto's dad so
I'm pretty sure that there's gonna be
that's gonna be part of the deal they
should find out the what happened to
Otto they should find the people who who
were responsible for that horrible
horrible treatment and they should
punish him I think that says that's as
big to me personally I know it may seem
irrational as HAP making sure that their
inspectors there to look at the make
look at their nukes but I think it
should be part of it because you can't
let him get away with that but obviously
you know the sanctions worked and the
sanctions work because they're like it's
like I would call the sanctions the
Trump handshake right
it's the handshake that doesn't let go
and just gets tighter and tighter and
tighter that's what we're going to coin
that the Trump handshake because it can
go it can go on forever there's no end
to these sanctions if you're going to
always make them worse and I think
they're realizing that this isn't going
the way they want to go off so he
targeted companies which is kinda new I
mean you target you target countries but
you target their companies that's kind
of interesting but I am I am skeptical
but I will also say this that like it's
it's an interesting contrast between how
Republicans do that due to foreign
policy and Democrats Democrats are like
the single parent but Republicans are
like both parents you've got you've got
that you've got the carrot in the stick
and Democrats always think all they all
you have to do is yell world peace and
it'll happen no you actually need
a carrot and you need a stick and I
think Trump has been really good at
wielding that stick okay Juan well I'm
just puzzled because I mean I I think
what I heard was rhetoric that was
threatening hostile and made people fear
that President Trump might in fact
decide it was time to do a unilateral
strike against North Korea I don't think
it led to this I think what led to this
was the South Korean president actually
taking the risk of coming together and
saying you know what we want to reunify
we want the peninsula to be one why
don't you North Koreans join us at the
Olympics March in with us let's talk
let's have some talks remember that
we're going to be talks between vice
president Pence who went those talks
broke down but the South Korean
president did meet today you have a
situation where Rex Tillerson our
Secretary of State says as you saw at
the start of the show it's a surprise to
us speaking of the Trump administration
that you get Kim changing his posture in
this way and today at the White House
Sarah Huckabee Sanders was kind of
unsure saying oh you know what we want
to make sure that he is going to as a
precondition to any talks denuclearize
first and then other people said oh no
they're agreed to have the meeting but
seriously Sarah Huckabee Sanders
statement made it seem like we're not
quite sure about this and then Tillerson
said sitting that the talk is not
negotiation so I think to myself the way
that we're casting this conversation is
big win for Trump or not is he getting
enough credit or not and I'm just
thinking the real issue here is how do
we deal as a country with North Korea
and are we doing so effectively but the
South Koreans were the first ones to say
it was the presence of Donald Trump
position he took that led to this
position and Obama's policy of
appeasement was getting us nowhere other
than going backwards I don't think it
was appeals man I think in fact if you
go back to Republican administrations if
you go back even like to George HW then
Clinton then George W and then Obama all
of them have tried in some way to make a
deal it's not I think they're failing I
think it's the failing of the North
Korean regime to hold to their word and
their word was you know like what the
six-party talks
or we're gonna make it they always lie
but you what you did you actually kind
of like you nailed it by mentioning all
the past presidents this one's obviously
different
we actually are the crazy person on the
street for once and that is working he
is unpredictable you don't know what is
going to do and unpredictability is a
great car to have in your hand if north
korea finally was facing somebody who
might actually nuke you that's a first
they didn't expect anybody else to do
that but this guy might actually do it
and they're thinking you know what with
the way the sanctions are going the way
they're going after companies this guy
it's not gonna end well for us and it
may still not end well for Kim because
the other thing we're not talking about
is and and I disagree one I'm not
presenting it as good for Trump or bad
but I'm I'm worried about the people in
North Korea because they still got they
you know we still have to address that I
mean if they're still starving
you know do we want to say it took great
you know it probably is better for the
world that he's deed nuclear ties but
what about them I just wonder if the
rhetoric you me everybody seems to be
saying oh because Trump had this
bellicose rhetoric that shifted Kim's
posture I don't know that I apparently
that house in order to I mean you that
you we know yes it is all of it is a
piece of part of the equation know why
except but there's one other thing that
I think we don't know a lot about and
Dennis Wilder was on the two o'clock
show today and he said that the Chinese
have done something that have changed
the way that the Kim regime has able to
use currency and that it that is we
don't I don't understand how that all
that dark money stuff works but
basically if he'd if the regime doesn't
have a way to pay off the generals in
order to keep them in line then he
realizes he's got to have to is going to
have to do something and they have a
South Korean president now that they did
not have during the Obama administration
who is much more willing to say to the
North Koreans let's try to work this out
and that it just depends on who you end
up with and right now what we've ended
up with is a president who is willing to
do what it takes to stop North Korea
from having a nuclear weapon and you
have Kim jong-un squeezed enough that
he's finger and well let me try this
gambit and see if I can like get him to
the taste it really doesn't convince
in terms of it you know his approach but
I think it is part of the the puzzle and
the piece that has worked here because
it serves you only think it really
different in terms of what you look at
different thing he has a nuclear weapon
now yeah well that to Britain and then I
also think there's the China piece in
terms of their influence behind the
scenes and putting pressure well Dennis
Rodman go I hope so because he because
he could be the super happen let's not
dumb down the segment